yes i welcome you to
today's lecture on
friedrich wilhelm hegel regel is
undoubtedly one of the most important
philosophers of the occident and
i hope to be able to show you today
that hegel's great discovery is
actually one of the finest
that philosophy as a whole has to offer
however, i have to say that a
language is very peculiar i brought you
numerous quotes as always
and jäggle was already criticized during his
lifetime by contemporaries of
schopenhauer because he speaks in a very convoluted,
abstract, passionately
intensive way and actually very incomprehensibly for many
, including today’s
philosophy students
always complain and schopenhauer said his
language hegel language is like the
language you use in their houses and
mad houses higher yes so
bitterly angry and also the modern
culture critic the jews of the
american culture philosophy young
writes every books are most  works
of incomprehensibility but
you shouldn't be put off by that, although
i have to admit that i have in my
philosophy studies here is my
paperback set of rules edition too well
it took me almost a whole year
to be able to read these books fluently at all understand that
again  something else and you can see to
this day only a few volumes are
by no means all tattered but i
can assure you it is
worthwhile to deal with
hegel because he is the
first philosopher to have the great dimension of
becoming, i.e. the development of becoming
in its entirety  scope recognized
everything really everything is in
constant motion to be cared for human life
has just as much a process character as the
history of
mankind, for example the child comes as an infant the little person is born
then it is a small child that recognizes
then at some point it becomes more youthful
comes into the  puberty and so on  it
develops and in the same
way the entire human race develops from the
simplest beginnings, i.e. in the
stone age up to modern times, mankind
goes through the most diverse
development phases and now comes the
interesting speech of these epochs has
its own truth, yes, a very
own truth and that’s why  can he
set up the radical thesis that
everything changes, not just
architecture, music, politics,
philosophy, no, truth
itself also changes over time,
maybe here's a small example
, aristotle and the ancient
greeks thought it was that's it  by
nature there were two kinds of people
, the citizens who are free and the
slaves and
aristotle himself counted the slaves among the panthers among the
household goods and it was only a
philosopher nowadays we would
say is of course untrue all
people have the same right  in
their human dignity anerka  nnt
have the right to develop mentally physically
and nobody is allowed to
believe what others
say
or what is happening in the basement so the truth itself says tegel is also in motion as well as our
feeling for justice
or the laws that change
is constantly has process
character and  if you ask here now
what is the absolute truth
if every epoch has its own
truth then hegel answers something an
exciting i brought
you a very fine quote from hegel the truth
is the whole thing
and the whole thing is just that through  its
development had been completed so
the truth is all said here
so that one cannot now
look at a single epoch neither in
antiquity were right nor the middle ages
nor but one must
have understood the entire development and only in
this development is it completed
whole and that interests us because that
is ultimately the truth
good  when we talk today is he tempted by the
so-called zeitgeist everyone
knows the zeitgeist so what
do I know about us handy mode jones --she's there
is the shirt andy warhol everything possible
is bells in the zeitgeist yes
then we know immediately what is meant
but that  today we can speak of the same time
that hegel’s
phenomenology of spirit goes back
to hegel’s philosophy because
hegel was the first to say that time
has its own spirit its own
spirit shape everyone in the room knows
hegel that has something to do with world spirit
and  we will get
closer to this idea of the world champion as a first hint i would like to tell
ou take the zeitg
ist the world spirit is first of all nothi
g other than the zeitgeist and t
is zeitgeist of a certain epoch
has a spiritual principle and this
rinciple is then refle
ted everywhere in architecture  in music
in art in fashion everywhere
and now the zeitgeist is changing
from epoch to epoch
i brought him a nice quote again the
spirit has worked out and expanded the principle of the specific
level of its self-confidence
every time in the whole richness of its
versatility
it is
a rich spirit the spirit of a people
an organization a dome of multiple
vaults  corridors pillars rheinhallen and
departments has what it means now the
spirit has the principle of the specific
level of its self-confidence every
time in the whole wealth of its
diversity output that doesn't mean
us simply so the zeitgeist
basically has the principle let's take it in
principle let's take it  let's take it in
principle let's take absolutism
yes absolutism also has a
certain spiritual principle you
may all know the sun
king the famous french king louis
kartons the location his
platform shoes had this white wig
on and he once said the sentence l'etat
c'est moi the state  am i the
sun king he said because in
absolutism there was a very specific
principle, namely the absolutist
rule principle that there is only one
ruler the king by god's
grace appointed by god himself when he
was of course the son of the previous year's
king and thus became king  but
that was just divine providence that he is
the child of the king and he has the
entire power he had the power over
the army over the taxes over all the
ministers and ruled absolutely and so
was the architecture too so
we'll look at that again  here the citation
to the spirit has the principle of the
certain level is a
self-confidence so the
absolutistic spirit zeitgeist worked out
this absolutistic principle in
all
its diversity and with all the riches that means in
absolutism the castle was
built like that the architecture there was a
main house for the king and right and
left lower wings there  nn for the
aristocracy even lower and also the park
the french garden for example
it is cut to size there no grass grows any
differently and everything points to the
king to absolute power yes the
french gardens are taught differently than
english taught one-sidedly aligned
to the central radiant king  figure
so from both sides of the
castle all roads could lead to
this castle also the cascades the
water supply the canals everything and at
this time that is why we are talking about
wealth yes it is a rich spirit the
spirit of a people an organization a
cathedral with vaulted rooms etc  can say yes
, if in absolutism
the loungers all had these white wigs
yes, the spirit is also reflected
in fashion the platform shoes on
everything they wanted to look a bit like the
king and all
over europe they built the castles of the
sun king  yes and
heard the same music handle
then you heard mozart  yes you
have all heard the idea of baroque music yes b
roque lifestyle and that's why we ca
say here the zeitgeist works at every
stage of its development everything in fa
hion architecture music and so on so
in all lengths forms of desig
will
he spirit materialize well
ow i
it's like that now let's leave
it at that jäggle made this great
discovery that there are something like
epochs there is a sequence of
spirit forms now you can say that
's not a great achievement yes each of
us will say clearly that I exist  can
also do a quick test with you
if i name any phenomenon now,
for example
acropolis then you
know exactly when acropolis is mentioned acropolis is this
greek temple that belongs in the
spirit form and in the epoch of
antiquity in ancient greece in
classical antiquity yes there  are there the
states, the columns, etc. when i say
ritterburg, you immediately know
ritterbu  rg belongs to the spirit form of the
feudal middle ages knight medieval
feudal lords yes belongs to
christianity middle ages knight's castle knightly we
can immediately assign individual phenomena to
the zeitgeist to the respective
zeitgeist that's actually nothing
special we know who would
doubt that they
're throbbing romanesque gothic
baroque rococo  and second renaissance
enlightenment nobody would doubt all these things
now but hege
has a second one and now
many important benefits are being made exciting,
namely that these different forms of spirit are
not randomly connected to each other
these epochs were not
rolled but the consequences of
a very specific one  course of logic
namely the famous dialectic one
epoch emerges from the other he
brings this beautiful example here
first with the plant he says quote
the plant does not lose itself in mere
inappropriate change is no
coincidence the germ is nothing to the germ  hen
he has the drive to
develop many things emerge that is
already contained in the germ of course
not developed but enveloped and
ideas the completion of the put out
struggled a goal is set the
highest come out of oneself that
predetermined end is the fruit
so he tells us here that basically the
entire historical development is
structured like this, comparable to a plant
we have the seed we have the
seedlings we have the leaves the
bushes and so on and in the
end we have the flowers and the fruit and it
grows just as brilliantly logical  also in
the history of mankind one epoch
approaches from the other,
however, now there is another
special feature in the history of mankind
or also in the
individual human being, this growing up is
not just generative growth, as you say,
but it
takes place in crises and
contradictions, just take a
pubescent one  child when the child in the
puberty comes it's often pretty
horrible because it no
longer accepts what the adults say what the
teachers say what the school paramedics say
but it like self-determined life ass
defends itself it goes into resistance but
this negation this antithesis
eventually dissolves into a synthesis and that
child becomes calmer again but
we have it similarly in the whole history of the
world we are driven on by the
tick what is
dialectics you may remember
from school thesis antithesis synthesis that
means you have a certain knowledge
all of a sudden you develop the opposite to it
an against  knowledge and from this counter-
knowledge a third knowledge arises
namely the synthesis and
that
says hedgehog takes place thousands of
times that constantly
gets lost in history so the epochs have a
thought we already know that a
principle every epoch has a spirit principle and
then developed  in the next
week the opposite and the against
enteil is governed more and more strongly
the new principle of the next epoch
hunters shows us that a nice
example is the french
revolution
he says before the revolution the whole
condition of france at that
time was a wild aggregate of privileges
against all thought and reason
a realm of injustice anyway
why does he say that because in france
shortly before the revolution the
kings or the king and the nobility in
let's just encourage and
celebrate and sucked the people dry there were
famines bad famines in paris
and it was too  a realm of injustice
if there was no equality of rights
if a farmer sued against the building
then the nobleman was right
but if the farmer got into
problems with his concerns then he was
lost because the nobleman was also
the judge with blue blood and so
on  and france was therefore,
hegel, a kingdom of injustice then
the new spirit became t  active big disco the
enlighteners said it's not possible
why do we need a king how he
should govern the people if not the
people and new ideas of
popular sovereignty came up yes and rousseau
called for direct democracy and
more and more people shared these new
ideas  that's why the
new spirit says yes, the change
was necessarily violent because the
reorganization was not carried out by the government of
course the king has
not resigned that's why they made a
revolution and king and
queen beheaded the idea the concept
of law now joined in  applied once
and against it the
framework of injustice could not
resist it was therefore a glorious
sunrise so hegel celebrates the
french revolution as a glorious
sunrise when he says in
absolutism towards the end of
absolutism the whole thing was just a system of
injustice then this new one came along  spirit
on against this mi  medieval
absolutist structure
and said there is no such thing as blue blood
the king is not a king because the son
of the king is that is bad
rule rule must be based on
democracy only the people
can determine who rules the people
not just anyone whose child gets and
then his child will be like the king for him that's
a completely new idea and that new
spirit figure you all know what it's
called that's the enlightenment to take
the place of absolutism third in
all of europe the enlightenment an enormous
awakening and rationalism
superstition would be driven out  one
also no longer believed in blue blood all the
more yes a whole new spirit figure
had risen in the sky hence the
wonderful sunrise
well
let's go to the next quote from
hegel also wonderful again the spirit kingdom
is a succession in which
one replaced the other and each the
kingdom  the world took over from the previous one
also very important yes we
have different spirit forms from antiquity to the present day
and heaven
therefore speaks of a whole
realm of spirits yes we have it we
have many epochs and each epoch
takes over something from the previous
one and brings it to a
higher level and  this happens not only
in world history and with us
personally in our personal
development but also in
science its title
science also only works through
this great engine of dialectics
dialectics always means thesis antithesis
synthesis
example for a long time people
believed the world is  a pane and
the sailors were even afraid of flying over the
pane if they
extended further they may then came a
counter-thesis namely that the world is not flat but and
that was of course denied by the
church and for a long time there were
heated discussions but  at some
point this  being able to establish a new opinion as a
synthesis that the earth is and is
and even carries itself around itself yes
that was the synthesis then this
synthesis became the thesis again and
suddenly because the thesis says yes the
earth is and revolves around itself
and this in the  the center of the universe
and all around are the stars and the
other planets all arranged
for a long time as the prevailing opinion as
truth as truth but as
hegel says, truth is also
in motion and at some point
copernicus came along and said we are unfortunately
not at all in the center and  the stars
are all around us but we are on the
edge of the universe and we revolve
around the sun it's not like
the sun and everything revolves around us but
we revolve around ourselves yes and again and
again theesen has had a new
opinion  formulated and that goes on and
on with quantum physics up to the theory of
relativity in general every
scientific f  progress is always
a struggle thesis antithesis synthesis and
the synthesis again becomes the thesis and
so the whole world
continues to develop
now we have seen that
[music]
the owner also has that nice so
i'm talking so remember this language
it is you can remember  also get involved in
his language and
at some point you love this formulation
the possession of self-confident
reasonableness which belongs to the present
world is an inheritance and the
result of the work of all
previous generations of the
human race is not nice
all our knowledge is what we have
today  ultimately an inheritance and the
result of the work all these many
generations of human history have
begun that have researched before us
also wonderful I think you will notice
which
virus has paved the way by
saying it people there is no timeless
truth everything is in motion and now
comes the cow  this also applies to him for
g  ott yes it applies to him for god too
god says heger is not some
instance that hovers above everyone up in the
sky and in the end judges whether we
have lived well or badly and then
punishes or rewards us, so to speak, or we
then have eternal life no god
hovers  not above everyone but god
himself is in motion and that of
course brought you the enmity of the church
because he says even in the beginning
there was no god at all god
only came to himself in the course of human history
so there was no such thing as the beginning
he has not yet developed his
self-confidence, but it
develops with us through us through
the people, god
first achieves his self-confidence and
now look at the quote because
world history is the representation of the
divine absolute process of the
spirit in its highest forms
gradual transitions whereby he reveals his
truth self-confidence about himself
e
so you see here he says god
or world history is nothing other
than the representation of the divine
absolute process that is nothing
else god is nothing other than the
history of mankind yes he
accomplishes himself and in
history that is why he
usually also speaks  not of god yes here he
speaks of the divine process of the
spirit usually speaks about it
world spirit and now we can
draw a conclusion here introductory
that was our first approach to the
world spirit
with hegel the human being is
world history and
ultimately nothing is different from each
other but all  three
moments the divine divine
unfolding the unfolding of our
individual
humanity and world history the
unfolding of the broken are just three
different perspectives of one and the
same dynamic of one and the same
development that is hegel's ingenious
idea which I have now
presented to you in an overview  and
now, of course, three crucial questions arise for us
, first,
what do I do this dialectic how
does it work, exactly how does the
dialectic drive this whole movement forward,
second,
where does it all end, yes, where does it
all end, what is the ultimate goal of
human history, that’s how it culminates
dialectics i will
give you the answer in a few minutes later and
thirdly we are of course also
interesting yes if the world
spirit is the dialectical self-development of thinking in
history, so to speak,
how is it then with us humans with
napoleon or cesar or alexander the
great  it's not that we humans
shape the story, or is it the
world spirit and if it's the world spirit,
then we're just there like puppets, so to speak
, or are we actors,
what do you say about that, i'll tell you that in a moment
, now let's take a look at each
other  the dialects can
and here i would like to give you a very
simple one  give an example
namely so everyone would
look at the individual dialectics because he
says yes in their heads also in the
heads of the individual people
nothing else happens is a dialectic
development of consciousness and
that since the stone age and that's why
I'll give you an example right away  from
the stone age you take some just
human who is hungry he pulls a
colorful mushroom then he is because
maybe it still has white spots on it and
glows red and then it was just let's say
a fly agaric but he doesn't know it
yet and then he gets
terrible things  stomach and throws up
and throws up again and comes down
on the ground to endure and then starts
and all the other primitive people from the hd
see lying behind and regret him and
see the half-eaten fly pizza
now we have two theses the first thesis
was he goes along there  prehistoric man and
pulls these wonderful mushrooms and thinks
i'm a person who's hungry and
the mushroom is a great mushroom that is
food all mushrooms i can eat mushrooms
are delicious to eat i eat pzst thesis
all mushrooms are edible and is
experience teaches the mushroom but that it is
not so and the antithesis is now
that prehistoric people see how  who
boasts he himself he vomited in march
and the antithesis is
mushrooms are poisonous and dangerous
you can eat them under no circumstances
happened now but
maybe the other person in the group or he
himself will one day have a little one
Brown mushroom and the well I'll try
again and suddenly you realize
you can eat it and then
at some
point you come to a synthesis and the
synthesis says it's not that
all pcs fit it's also not
that the mushrooms are basically inedible
are but some mushrooms you can eat
and some not and that is a
process of experience that has to
be made and as I said with every experience
let's change the awareness of
ourselves because we know we are people
who don't tolerate mushrooms then we
know we tolerate mushrooms and then
we know some we don't tolerate some
and we change the knowledge of the
object namely from the mushroom so and
now something exciting is coming along
it's easy thesis antithesis synthesis
but now something wonderful comes
along, namely with every synthesis
we make or even the antithesis to the
thesis, a process of cancellation happens
, in three senses of the
word cancel
that's also wonderful you
'll see
means cancel  for hegel, first of all,
that has three meanings, by the way,
in the german language too, the word
aufhaben has three horizons of meaning that
characterize daily dialectics and
now use them correctly for his dialectics
, that first of all,
the word aufhaben contains that the
contradiction is being lifted because  it
's a contradiction if you know  ss i
can't eat mushrooms and when you know
i can eat all mushrooms this
contradiction and in the synthesis
this contradiction is gone it is
abolished in the sense of away in the sense of
end
secondly but said there is a
second meaning of abolition and there
have  i think i brought a quote
with me that is here to keep has in
the language the double meaning that
it
means as much as to keep and at the same time as much as
to let stop making an end so to
cancel has a double meaning in the language
the first meaning is i
just explained to you that was that
means let it stop put an
end so the contradiction
stops the contradiction has an end the
contradiction stops the second are is
but keep cancel so we also
have the meaning of on the music of
conserve as well as man  photo picks up or
one cooks a jam, closes it and
picks it up for the winter or so on
level are of it  kept and that
means that and let's go back to our
dialectic thesis
even if we now have the synthesis
that some mushrooms are edible and others are
not, the knowledge from the thesis
that or from the anti-thesis that the
mushrooms are poisonous and the stomach
float remains  will be preserved in the sense of
kept that will never be completely forgotten
go to my forest picture collect it there is
light always remind everyone
of bell oppler it could be poisonous
so this experience of these generations
that is perhaps also in our
unconscious this is still lifted
that we know  damn toxic so it
doesn't get lost what is thesis was
and in the antithesis and remains in the
synthesis lifted and now comes the
third meaning it even has a
third meaning the word lift up
namely in the sense of listen lift up to a
higher level lift up lift up  in the sense
of lifting heights because he says here you
usually have to introduce yourself
the synthesis then becomes a thesis again
or in history all the
epochs that copy one another
they come there comes the spiritual form
and the spiritual movement the spiritual
self-development always on a higher
level so our knowledge today has a
higher quality than knowledge  what
you used to have in the original state or
in antiquity or in the middle
ages there is a constant process of abolition
that is the wonderful threefold
meaning of abolish in the sense of
preserving something of the
thesis in the synthesis in the sense of
eliminating the contradiction and the sense
of lifting that dialectic
development always lifts knowledge to higher levels
good
that's why hedl can say the general
spirit does not stand still they are in
constant motion the general spirit
and in world history it looks like this
i quote with a single
nation it may well be the case  its that
your education your art of knowledge  If your
mental faculties are above the
capital, that is to say, they will be more or less static,
as seems to be the case with the Chinese, for
example,
who 2000 years ago may have been as advanced in everything as
the spirit of the
world is now, but does not sink into this
indifferent calm  life is
indeed interesting that he says yes the
spirit is in constant motion and
pushes the epochs apart in
front of it and develops further
except in china it seems so in china
said yes there seems is that may well be
the case  that the chinese seem a bit static when it comes to
education, art,
science
, because you really have to think
about the lever of his time when
hegel lived was children a bit
backwards is a purely agrarian
nation that still had the same
medieval structures  like
2000 years ago, they hadn't
developed much and that's why tegel says
it may seem so  that
there is no development in china at the moment or
taking place but overall the spirit
will not rest the spirit will continue to
develop
that is why he says in the last sentence
the spirit of the world does not sink into
indifferent calm the spirit of the world
is entered his life is rath well quite
crucial  and as we know today
he was right
sooner or later in china too, so to speak,
a dialectic development has
set in around
children is today one of the a very
modern nation that is now at home in everything at the
top of the world
and that  his thesis is that basically there
is a constant dialectical evolution
and so he can say i quote
the story again is that becoming this
becoming represents an inert movement and
succession of spirits as a
gallery of images each endowed with the
complete richness of spirit
that's why it moves so sluggishly
because that itself this whole
penetrating and digesting wealth of its substance
has good spirit to
say again is another of hegel's great boxed sentences
but
it all makes sense so the story is
that becoming that's clear the story
is a constant becoming is a
development and that becoming represents
an inert movement  because why is the
story a sluggish movement you but
the feeling it goes really fast no
the story is sluggish that is justified
yes wonderful
that is a sluggish where is it here sluggish
movement and sequence of ghosts a
gallery of pictures is also clear to us
so gallery of  pictures,
so to speak, why hannig renaissance gothic and so on
so these are always formations
yes you can see them pictorially in
front of you these spirit shapes and they
are therefore sluggish here based it
just moves so sluggishly because it
itself so the the the movement the the
dialectic must
penetrate and digest the whole richness of the substance every time
n
that means we are here again
basically he said that in the first quote
he is talking about a
cathedral with capitals with benches with rooms with
columns yes and you know every epoch
has to change the whole richness of its
substance with every new epoch
we have a new fashion we have new
clothing styles we have a new philosophy
new ideas we have a new legal system
we have new laws we have
new music in every epoch so
the music is constantly changing we have
a new architecture so and that’s why he
can say it’s changing with it  with every
new spirit shape or in
everything just become so sluggish because everything is
being implemented and it is also
amazing as always in every new
epoch where new central spiritual
principle prevails everything with the environment is
good and
now comes the exciting thing now
we are going to present it for the first time  the question
where does it all go where does it all
go yes what is then the end of this
gallery of  pictures that shape the mind
that have been developing since the Stone
Age where does everything lead and
the interest that is of course burning
and above all in which direction
it is going and i will now give the first
preliminary answer reveals and
actually where the story is going he
says it is very simple  history
goes
in the direction of
freedom people are trying to realize more and more
individual and social
freedom in their lives
and he gives us a very nice quote he
says world history is progress
in the awareness of freedom,
progress that we
have to recognize in all its necessity
world history is progress in the
consciousness of freedom so the
consciousness of us humans the
consciousness of living freely
wanting to live freely and feeling free that is
increasing there is progress in the
consciousness of freedom if you look at the
whole history and that gives
us  the direction ahead and the
Interestingly enough, this progress awareness of freedom is a necessary one and
now let's go into detail
rules can say as I say in the next
quote wonderfully the orientals do
not yet know
that the spirit or the human being as
such is intrinsically free because the
orientals are not aware of it  you
don't either you only know that
someone is free see the quote the
orientals don't yet know that the
spirit or the human being as such
is intrinsically free because they don't
know it they aren't either they only know
that someone is free  a single you
know how it was in the ancient orient in
persia or something like that there was a big
can a big king and all the others
were slaves the big can could
at any time command any of his subjects
to go to their deaths and
that's what they did  there was
only one who was free and all
others were free the next
progress in history through the
constant dialectic un  d the
further development was then the
greeks
here says as a rule in the
greeks the awareness of freedom first
arose and that is why they were
free but they just like the romans
knew that some are free
not the human being as such
even plato and aristoteles knew this
not and we only had at the beginning of the
lecture
the greeks the citizens were free to choose they were allowed to
vote we chose their district parts
and the slaves were of course there too they
shouldn't be there they were
slaves so that's why kegel says some
were free  the greeks knew only
in the greeks came the awareness of
freedom but they only knew that
some are free and
not that man as such is
free and now what is interesting
now says the first germanic
nations have also come to awareness
that freedom of spirit  his
own nature makes up so only the
germanic natures are
conscious  it came to be that the freedom
of the spirit makes up its own nature
that means that people are suitable
human nature is freedom and
that only
came to the consciousness late in the germanic states, so to speak
, although one can of course
say that the french revolution
was in france  they were the
first to say egalitarianism liberté fraternité i.e. equality
freedom
fraternity why the germanic
instead of saying quite simply about
christianity and this religion that
everyone is equal before god the idea that everyone could be equal developed earlier in the
nordic states
and that was the beginning of the
idea of freedom, which was later implemented in the frenc
revolution and the o
her constitutional states, but y
u can see that
he trend in history is th
t the dialectic means more and more progr
ss in the awareness of freed
m and now  comes the
interesting i  he is now saying the
idea of freedom that is all well and good but y
u can only realize it in the state
as long as we don’t have
state entity you can talk about freedom but u
timately you n
ed judges you need a police force you need an ap
aratus that sees to it  that
one does not enslave
the other that one does not simply take something from the other who
knocks him down or what
steals individual freedom
we can only realize in the state and
that's why said that this that man in and
for himself is nothing that clamer rey is
intended not again  a mere should not
again be understood as a mere should
this is only found in the
city's recognition that the idea of
m is truly only possible as the state, so th
idea of freedom is truly only
ossible as a state only the city realizes th
s idea of freedom if
e  state can ensure that the
individual individuals are treated fairly and
equally as equals
deal with others and that everyone is treated according to the same
law yes and that
human dignity is guaranteed for everyone's free development
that services are
only given to the city and therefore heavy
daily by the state look at the
state is the reality of concrete
freedom so the state is the
realization  freedom is
interesting because someone would say
the city of lights rules me so much
no he said the city is the
realization of freedom he goes even
further the state is the reality of
the moral idea yes the state is what
is sensible in and of itself  the state
is the reality of the moral idea
because for hegel the morality of the
state even has priority over the
morality of the individual
, i.e. it is a physical activity of the state
that guarantees that the individual can behave in a
harmful way if he can only behave within
this framework
and mainly
morally takes place well
that comes from a  lso that was also
criticized, for example,
papa criticized it or various
others criticized Hegel for that reason,
then said he would have been the Prussian state
philosopher, you know, he
also had a chair in Berlin
and the king also listened to his
lectures in Prussia  back
then it was indeed a constitutional state had
a constitution and there was also a
permanent right to vote already is was a
preliminary stage of democracy but of
course by no means the complete end of
democracy and the state also praises the lever
like that of course has disadvantages if you
say morality only comes  the
state
can of course
encourage totalitarianism and
karl popper, for example, also
criticized hegel for this, but we must not forget one thing: the
rule has
of course also described the tasks of the state in
detail, for example the rule has described
that the state
has certain tasks that
exist there  precisely the freedom of the
individual si  to create and to do
so equally and so comes the very
progressive statements that only the
state can guarantee that everyone is allowed their
human dignity,
regardless of whether they are rich or poor,
what their origin is and what
nation and race or origin they
belong to, he writes the human being is valid
because he is human not because he is jew
catholic protestant german italian
and so on and that is quite an
achievement at this time to be so far-
sighted well now we come to the next
quote let's leave that there we come
to his concept of god  who is
now getting very exciting we have now
seen how the individual
develops thinking dialectically we have
seen world history dialectically
securing its contradictions advances from the
professional to the epoch
now we actually come to the much
invoked world spirit or to god everyone
always knows hegel is the way to go  around the
world spirit but everyone only has e  a vague idea of the world spirit is no
a specter waving a sword around somewhere but u
timately it is exactly the same
ovement of thinking that basic
lly takes place in the individual and in world
history and h
ge therefore also criticizes the catho
ic church or chris
ianity in general and says yes it is
madness to assume that there is
an unmoved god who
hovers over everything that can't be and he
also makes fun of the
catholic church and says that in the
service in the
catholic liturgy a man is handed a rusty
one with the words this is my
body
take jesus christ and asset all of it
and so on and ever said by
eating the body of christ
you try to take in
the savior and the spiritual and the
divine, so to speak, that is
a kind of identification that the
spirit jumps over to the believers yes
and  the rule makes fun of it
and says the world spirit  who has
always been
there in the whole history of mankind does not need to
be passed on to people via a rusty one,
but he is and
always wants to be with us and if
the catholics may be right about the
world spirit or god about them  definition,
so to speak, pass on the sanctity to the people
what happens then and
it had said in a lecture to its
students what happens then
when the dough tarver nail paint gap
remains open by mistake and in the mouse
slipped into the tabernacle and eats
these wafers when the mouse then
goes out and leaves a
heap of code then the catholics would
consequently also have to take the heap of faeces as a
saint
that is secured to the outside and igls
then had to apologize for it the
students defended him
saying that would not have said that we
actually had to
officially apologize for it but
this small example shows how w  since we were
already away from the classic
concept of god so the world spirit is
movement it is basically the
world spirit itself the dialectic is
perhaps the best answer
good
and he now says the insight to
which philosophy should lead is that the
real world is like it  it should
also be interesting yes that the true
good is the general divine reason
also the power to
accomplish oneself god rules the world the
content of his government the presentation of
his plan is world history so
again god does not float everywhere
but god says here he
takes again  the quote
god is the divine reason is
at the same time the power to
accomplish itself so the divine reason
has the power and the possibility to
accomplish itself in nature in
history and in the individual human being it
doesn't swim somewhere
but it's in there  and
also happens in history there is
no difference  hied between the
world spirit and human history
that is ultimately 1 that's why he can
say here in the second sentence god rules the
world the content of his government the
presentation of his plan is
world history yes
now this question arises that we asked
at the beginning if
the world spirit actually as  dialectic
predetermined logical process determines the
entire history of the world well if
that's the
case the individual person
can do something or can we lean back and relax
because the world spirit
makes history or is it not
actually that people like
all the great ones or napoleon or even
whole  governments or peoples
we call the people and then make a
revolution and what effect
is it the world spirit or are we the
actors in history and
now a very interesting construction comes up
with everyone he says there are
already so-called world-historical
individual countries like that
napoleon eg d  they move a lot
but said they are all people who have
special qualities who know
what is at the time we see that here
but at the same time they are completely normal
people made of flesh and blood but
at the same time they were thinking who had an
insight into what was going on  time
is so you have to know what the time
is then you will have political and
global political and historical success
if you are really rice water at the
time so for example i don't know
if you still remember the sentence of gorbachev
who comes too late punishes you
history or whoever comes too late is
punished by life
gorbachev said to honecker veronika wanted to keep the old
socialist system and
gorbachev noticed that
socialism was on its knees break that you can
no longer maintain these old forms like
the
german one  division not and said
if you don't
hurry up, so to speak, then i overtook the
story  this is a deeply rule
not thought of yes because as a world
historical personality you have to
know what the time is and if you
don't know it the world spirit comes and
still goes on history goes
on then you are
overtaken by history and napoleon was
one of those  figure who knew, by the way, rule
also says there are still these world
historical personalities like
cesar, etc., they are servants of the world spirit, they are servants of the world
champion,
who do what he is doing at the time,
we also know what the time
is, but if you  it doesn't matter if you don't know
because
the world spirit makes you do it
i'll give you an example now
napoleon has come to power
in every country in france first
and then in every country that the french
conquered or napoleon conquered
he  the so-called code civil introduced
the short wants that the civil
code and that was then that is
not clear to us today  still thinking about the
code but it was a revolution
because for the first time in europe there was suddenly
a code after the nobles were
sentenced according to the same
law as the peasants no matter who did something wrong the
same laws apply
and the judges were
suddenly no longer the good guys  that
was enormous progress and here we heard
it said it was time it was
time
to implement this idea
absolutism was at the end the
enlightenment broke out and that's why
it was time and that's why napoleon was introduced as
a good servant of the
cosmopolitan spirit of the wine village  but when
napoleon suddenly relapsed and
he let himself be emperor for life he
is completely
undemocratic he has
the power to terminate his relatives and so on and
so forth he has completely fallen
behind what he was actually
based on at the beginning  his ideas egalité
liberté fraternité he
thought and believed revolutionary ha  t and
promptly dropped in the world spirit like a
wet potato he became insignificant he
was first bandaged after saint
helena and then it was over with him at some point
and
now hegel says
that you can stand up to history even as an
individual
but you get overtaken by history
and overall it's like that of
course we
should be involved we should get involved in history
and we always do and
interestingly enough he often says politicians are
n't even that
thoughtful or what
personalities they are  think i
have to bring the world to a higher
level but they often only think of
themselves and their own
passions but through a trick of
reason they
bring it on to society, so to speak, that's
why he can
say that's the trick of reason to
name them  lets the passions
work for you,
so reason lets the
passions work for you  do napoleon
etc believe they might do it
out of passion out of a thirst for power but in the
end the superordinate
dialectical reason lets these people work
for themselves without them noticing and
if they don't do it anymore then
they no longer play a role in the
story it's always both you  you know
, in history, too, good new
ideas often appear in many places of humanity
at the same time that is the dialectic
idea that the world spirit pushes things
madly when new ideas are
born everywhere individual individuals
drive faster or slower
but ultimately it is the interaction
of both  so he tries to
resolve that we are both committed to action in any case
we are actors of
course because the spirit of the world is fulfilled in
us we are actors and of course we
should ensure
that history does not overtake us
but that we are the ones responsible for
the new  time work well
jet  currently there is also something wonderful
, namely this quote that we are
looking at now is very very important
is a quote that is also being discussed
by many and is not properly understood by most of it
that is
also very strange at first glance let's take a look at it
what is reasonable is
real and what is real is
reasonable so at first it sounds
nonsensical why should what is
reasonable be real and what is
real is also reasonable
that is fundamentally
related to the fact that reason is ever said to be
in the story  inside because this
dialectical self-development is
nothing other than the development of
reason and because reason
develops in history
everything that happens historically is
reasonable the entire
reality is reasonable now you
can say yes but what about the
burning of witches that was it
terrible that wasn't
reasonable that was superstition or  he
adriano a modern philosopher says yes
here it is common sense philosophy
that dialectics keeps
elevating history to a new, more reasonable level
that can't be at all otherwise there would
n't be something like fascism like the
holocaust and things like that about it
would be the norm yes  there are
setbacks but these antitheses are also
a synthesis of
today's modern city trying
not to make the mistakes anymore trying to
ensure in the constitution that
there can never be more fascism
so every generation learns from the
temporary and  these steps backwards
are of course also a reality, which is
why hegel can say everything that
happens is real and therefore also
somewhere reasonable, but of course
it is overtaken again in the negation and even
further lifted to higher, better levels
and because of this right-wing extremist
because he says the dialectic is the
movement  law also said well
basically everyone has  s people also the government
that deserves it yes we too today we
elect the government and for weeks
the government will scold the government in many weeks
but we have the government
that we deserve or regulate success
would also say quote every people has
the constitution that it  is appropriate
and belongs to the same thing, so every people
has the constitution that is appropriate to them
because if the people, let's say the
people lived under dictatorship and have a
constitution that is st motory,
then the people
have to go into negations, they have to go into resistance  it has to
fight and try to take it to the next
higher level and if the
people are not yet able to do that, yes,
then this old constitution is
still appropriate for the people, so that
's all that's really it's reasonable
everything that's reasonable is it  really what
does he mean by that we are of course
provocative of many he says in the
condition you have you have it because
he doesn't have the negative  n have gone
well so far
and now we come to something very
exciting, namely now we come to
the crucial question
where is the entire development of
the earth headed for mankind and the
individual where does the story really end
a highly exciting question
that hegel answers for us and I him
now i will answer yes where is the
goal of this dialectic thought process
we now know the dialectic a3
perspectives of man that is us
ourselves history and the development
of the world spirit there are three different
perspectives of the
same movement of the spirit
but where end where where leads the real
we  have already heard it goes in the
direction of freedom ever
greater realization in freedom but where
does it end and now hegel tells us a quote
the goal but is just as
necessary to knowledge as the series of progress
it is there where it no longer
goes beyond itself  has to go where
it finds itself that's not
great  g so he says the goal of
dialectical self-development the goal of
our thinking and acting in
history and in the epochs
is that at some point this system of
thesis antithesis synthesis and the
synthesis becomes the thesis again and
there is another antithesis etc. that
this system to  calm comes because we
have reached such a high state
through the constant abolition and hip
moral higher elevation of
societies yes at some point
in human history
we will be at a point where we can no longer go beyond ourselves
if we have done everything we
can  the
contradiction no longer exists so he
says at some point we will be there where it is no
longer necessary
to go beyond oneself yes where it finds itself
so the goal is knowledge knowledge
is again the spirit of course that's
our goal  so we celebrate our
knowledge is from the stone age to today
on ever higher level g  ebracht and
the goal of this development of knowledge
is ultimately
that it is ultimately that we
reach a point where knowledge
no longer has to develop further because
we have then
achieved absolute knowledge yes so here we are talking about
absolute knowledge the goal is absolute
knowledge or  knowing
oneself as a spirit the spirit knowing oneself as a spirit
the spirit
yes i see questioning faces we
can
discuss this in detail afterwards i won't be afraid i
will tell you now who that is i'll
tell you now who the absolute knowing
or the itself  the spirit itself knows
what is meanwhile knowing oneself the
spirit is again abstract but heaven is
concretized it gives us three
crucial hints how actually
at the end of the development of the dialectic
everything comes to an end namely in a
very great reconciliation and
we see this reconciliation  let us now
you know at the beginning of the story
is de  r primitive man alien to
everyone, above all, to the others, just
people who are perhaps natural as hunters
and gatherers when
they meet others you are frightened at first
who knows yes, I'll do something to you
, I don't care, he's completely alien to him
, the other one still seemed  in the age
of migration there came one
and the other and they hit themselves on
the head and
defended themselves defended the fertile valleys
against the others
people were strangers to each other
but in the course of the dialectic
of history people have always found each other
more approximately so yes there are
ever larger
mergers and finally there are no Bavarians Prussians
etc. then more but there are Germans
finally there are no more Germans
French English there is Europe
and eventually there
might be a world society at some point and as
I said in the dialectic the
following is happening now  in the dialectical self  st
movement of the spirit that the
completely alienated other, i.e. the
other person, is getting closer and closer and
i suddenly realize it makes no sense
to enslave the other or to say against the
other i even need the
other that he recognizes me in
my dignity and freedom  as i
recognize my dignity and freedom and
says at the very end of the story there
we come to a situation where the
total unity is there where the alienation is
completely canceled and where you see
where i feel as united that we
and one we that  i is that the
individual consciousness
feels as i that we and as we
that i is that means we know we
are a human being we also feel like
human beings we as individuals
do you understand the contrast is
completely eliminated we know we are
individuals but  at the same time we are part of
this humanity we are actually
primarily humanity and from this
humanity we feel a  as an individual
that can be the great
reconciliation at the end of the story in
our consciousness is of course
not yet reached
now but
we continue again nature let's take nature the
next great reconciliation is the
reconciliation of consciousness with the
resistant alien nature
nature is first of all something that is completely
outside of us think about the time
when those who had to fight against
wild animals and so on but also
later in the days of agriculture in the
entire agricultural society that we have had for
thousands of years when it  there was
hailing or you can
see weeds again then a fungus
came again then other animals came again then grasshoppers came again
have eaten everything up
so nature has always been understood as
something completely permanent and
outside of my
consciousness but
through thousands of years of dialectics
and self-development  we feel
more and more as part of this na  tur and you
know today we know that we are
made of amino acid mixtures of protozoa
many counters first creatures hominids
people in the people on not but
romania first primitive people and so sings
that we have developed since
darwin we know that we ourselves are part
of nature we
we are not alien to nature we are part of
this great nature and even modern
molecular biology tells us that we
the seams i ultimately share everything with
other creatures in the world even
i believe that not only with the
apes but also with the pigs
have an effect
common genetic structure and also
with other things of nature we are
natural beings we always affect each other more
than the sum of nature and that is
a great idea of hegel that he sa
s at the end of the dialectical devel
pment that we may not have reached at all  the
entire nature reconcile with us or
we with nature we  il we as
nature ever understand ourselves because
nature also says it is nothing other than
you this dialectic process that has
been driven in which we have
always participated so we can even get
as far as we thought so we also thought of
as  part of the
table and now i come to the
third and perhaps most powerful
final furious and vision of he also
says the consciousness he knows the god
in him
at the beginning of the
story we also understood god as something
alien yes he even
jumps victims when  then it hails and thunders
then he brings sacrifices to the god of thunder
so that in the next one
does not even know the harvest will not be negotiated
but little by little we understand ourselves as
the self-development of the divine and
we know that is coming is nothing
other than self-development he  is in
us in with us he needs us without us
he could not develop at all god
is ultimately only a person  pektive it
is nothing other than the history
of human development and at the end of
the story we will understand how we
feel we feel it we reach
a state of consciousness that then
tells us that consciousness, that is our
consciousness, recognizes god in us
consciousness recognizes god  so in it
we are compared or god humanized
as well as that is a great
and vision that stands at the end and in the
phenomenology of the spirit one of his
wonderful books that i
would perhaps recommend that you at least
try to read the introduction
then you will find it in  this
phenomenology of the spirit then shows
again this whole self-development,
this dialectical, the whole
thing, this tremendous dynamic and liveliness
that this development had and in the end he
says when the individual
actually knows itself to be absolute knowledge
and can no longer
go beyond itself, it feels like it is
all real  meness ever himself and and that
is his last great sentence with
which i would also like to end here he says
quote is a wonderful sentence at the
end again from the chalice this
realm of spirits clears his
infinity
thank you for your attention
[applause]